this i thought was a trickier line  because now if you go king e8 queen  takes g7 you might be worse  uh so you have  seven and king g8 does  and he played king e8 yeah king g8  probably just  loses to e7 now  because we can take on the f1 and go  king it soon  so blatantly clear because she was  obviously top 10 in the world in general  so she never participated very very  early in her career i think she made a  very conscious decision he played queen  of wall check here we're just kind of  that's cute just got scared yeah  i mean  as long as this is played like with a  chuckle and a smile it's yeah fine like  if you if you do this in a blitz game on  two seconds  it is because  it is considered it's slightly frowned  upon but  uh yeah doing in a classical  doing it in a classical game against 24  minutes you are not really trying to  angle shoot or anything you're just kind  of sharing a private joke with your  opponent about the importance of the f1  square there